so let's start talking about the new
york jets because they've got the second
overall pick in zach wilson
and uh
let's hear from zach wilson on winning
the starting job and also one of his
teammates on zach wilson's early
leadership chris here they are
in this position the coaches want to
play the best player and that that
position has got to be earned you know i
got to go in there and i got to make
sure i do what i'm supposed to do
and uh you know that'll take care of
itself talking about him on the phone i
could tell he's like a general you know
and just by what he was saying and you
know he's just
super excited to be here as well you
know
his passing comes out through the phone
and i'm ready just to watch him look
pretty throwing me balls
yeah the last thing i want to hear about
is a jets quarterback being excited to
be there 41 times over that brings back
memories of another jets quarterback who
wasn't there for very long but he was
extremely excited to be there about nine
years ago
uh as the zack wilson
you know he talked about having to earn
the starting job chris there's no
competition
for the starting job james morgan and
another guy whose name i think is mike
something that's it
that's all they have they don't even
have a veteran if zach wilson can't win
that starting job he never should have
been the second overall pick much less a
second round pick much less a third or a
fourth round pick no well i don't think
you got to worry about that he's going
to win the job i mean first off if you
just watch the local news up here like
how excited they were about him like
well you know what he brings to the
field and you know just from
conversations of people
that i know around the jets there was
excitement about him about what he looks
like in person you know how the ball
pops out of his hands like whoa yeah
it's a little different it's even better
than what i thought in purse or in
person than what i was on film at all
those type of things but yeah mike he's
the second pick of the draft they're
gonna roll out the red carpet he's gonna
get the reps all the work get all like
the mental reps everything like that and
they're gonna go down with zach wilson
now i would expect at some point that
they do bring in some sort of veteran
type quarterback to be the backup for
him and like we always talk about it's
good to have that guy too just because
you know you have somebody there to kind
of lay the groundwork or a foundation of
how you should work young rookie and
this is like this is what we do i know
i've spoken the past about brad johnson
and other guys i had in front of me you
know the example they set was the
biggest thing for me oh wait okay this
is what a starting quarterback does you
do this now all right no wait we broke
the meeting now you go and study more or
watch more film okay and those are the
things that they need a veteran presence
in the room for but you're right mike
he's the guy and he's going to get all
the refs because of that and there is
going to be no competition they're not
even going to try to pretend about that
i really am amazed that the nfl is now
drafting 13 year olds
i know this is funny he is yeah god
my god uh
now when you hear elijah moore another
member of the jets draft class praise
the leadership attributes of zach wilson
that's one thing what's the difference
between showing up at rookie mini camp
where you're clearly the king you're the
guy everyone's going to look to you
because you were the second overall pick
in the draft when the veterans start to
show up assuming that some do
whether it's
the remainder of the voluntary portion
or the mandatory mini camp that's when
they all will be there right when
everyone's there
what's the what's the difference between
acting like the alpha
among your fellow rookies where you're
ordained the alpha
and acting that way
when the guys who have been in the
league five seven ten years rolling yeah
you got to know your role is a little
different like you know you might be
able to be more the vocal hey guys
follow me do this type of stuff during
rookie mini camp right when it comes
veteran time and and the veterans come
around for whatever it is the mandatory
mini camp or an ota session whatever
that is yeah that's where
you want to be strong and confident as a
young quarterback you know you still
want to be a leader stick out your hands
say hello to guys but you're not going
to be the one that's like hey guys bring
it up you know i'm going to break you
down you know on three jets one no no
you're not gonna do any of that you kind
of have to take a little bit of a back
seat and kind of feel the room gauge the
room who are the leaders who should i
listen and follow to here and you just
kind of look to be a part of the team
that way and slowly you'll indoctrinate
yourself into knowing the guys and
becoming the leader of the football team
the guys want you to be the leader they
know he's the number two pick he's the
quarterback and all of those type of
things but he's just got to kind of
become one of the guys show that he
knows what he's doing on the football
field show his talents a little bit and
slowly but surely he'll start to take
over that room and that offense as it
goes by
you've told us before the way you were
welcomed to tampa by warren sapp and the
way that the rookies tend to get treated
when cadillac williams showed up a
couple of years later is the fifth
overall pick difference you get that
same kind of treatment is there
based upon how high you're drafted
that's how less you're treated like
you know the standard run-of-the-mill
third round quarterback who has to
supply warren sapp with his copenhagen
yeah no it's it's a different league
you're in when you're when you're yeah
cadillac williams or we had mike clayton
the great receiver from lsu who came
down to us you know as a top 15 pick
yeah they're going to get treated with
they're the shiny new toy
for the whole organization
let alone like in the locker room yeah
you get a different level of respect
being that first round pick you know one
whoa this guy's got some like special
physical attributes that he attributes
that he can bring to the team and help
us out to win football games and do all
that but also within being the first
pick you know how special that guy is to
the coaching staff and the front office
so you're not going to be a jerk or an
ass to him sorry black for lack of a
better phrase because of that type of
stuff and as long as you show respect a
little bit
again as that first round pick and
you're willing to work
you know then then you become one of the
guys really quick but yes there is a
different level of conversation with the
first the first round pick the second
round pick as compared to maybe the
fifth rounder who might have to earn his
stripes a little bit more than those top
guys
you know you came so close to giving us
a monday morning sims isn't before you
corrected yourself attribute
yeah attribute
attribute is what you wear on your leg
when you injure your calf muscle jumping
on and off a treadmill i think is that
that's how i'll define attribute yeah
that's the specific
yeah yes astro butte yeah
yeah yeah but you did you did
congratulations thank you you you heard
it and you fixed it and i'm sure that at
some point later this week when we're
sitting here waiting for the show to
begin
that's on the radar screen of clips that
you never know when they're going to
resurface yeah definitely um
and you know with some of these other
quarterbacks there really is a question
when we're going to see them we talked
about that some last week i think peter
and i talked about it on friday you and
i talked about it earlier in the week
the three guys take it after the first
two but for the first two
there's there's nothing to be earned
there's no lower rung on the depth chart
where you can put trevor lawrence i mean
i guess they could put him behind
gardner minshew you can't put zach
wilson behind anybody no no and i don't
know that it really matters i i think
part of the convention for nfl teams is
to bury the first round quarterback on
the depth chart and let him climb
so he can build some confidence and so
the teammates kind of organically
realize this is why the guy was brought
in here but with wilson that's just not
the case i don't care who they add as a
veteran and they're talking about
bringing in a veteran who the hell's out
there brian hoyer all due respect i mean
if zack wilson can't walk through the
door and be better than brian hoyer
again why were you a first round pick so
i it's yeah i mean those top two guys
and they will play this year we'll find
out wednesday night when trevor lawrence
and zach wilson will meet each other but
it won't be like it was
you know a couple of years ago when it
was what was the game
there were some games that were coming
up and it's like oh well will the guy be
a star oh yeah
baker mayfield arnold yes exactly yeah
week three but we didn't know tyrod
right yeah tyrod he knows
baker got to come in during that game he
wasn't starting he got to play and he
took over from that stand from that
point uh from that point on but yeah no
this is a different set of circumstances
there you're right mike i mean this is
more of like no there's nobody here and
no we're not going to like toy around
with yet gardner minshew or james morgan
get the first team reps no they haven't
earned enough stripes or done enough and
just aren't physically talented enough
to even like warrant putting guys like
trevor lawrence or zach wilson behind
them for a few days just to say you know
oh hey he earned it look at that no
they're just gonna this is these are the
situations it's more like a a peyton
manning back in the day with the colts
they've anointed these two the kings and
they're going to get reps and reps and
reps and reps and that's how they're
going to try to teach them football by
like hey we're not worried about anybody
else in here again any other quarterback
oh we got to give this guy we got to
give our our older veteran 10 reps this
period because he might be the starter
week one so let's do that no zach wilson
and trevor lawrence if there's a period
in practice mike where they have 20
plays during that period they're going
to get 15 15 out of the 20 reps and then
the other guy's gonna get a handful and
that's gonna be it and that's that's
where they're gonna get their learning
from right now but you'd like to see a
veteran around either one of them just
going forward
you know another reality of this trevor
lawrence and zach wilson dynamic
there really wasn't as matt casey
pointed out any question there was no
question not even really wasn't there
was no question lawrence was going to
the jaguars yeah and once it became
clear that that's where the jets were
going with wilson he got locked in there
there was never any
hesitation any question any
manning versus leaf type of debate
between lawrence and wilson so
it doesn't make it
as dramatic and compelling when they get
together because
no one's gonna be thinking well you know
what the jaguars really thought about
taking zack wilson and zach wilson came
down here and kicked the crap out of the
jaguars now that doesn't mean that
people won't say maybe they should have
but it's not the same
as if they did if they if they were
going back and forth and they agonized
over the decision and they didn't make
up their mind until the morning of the
draft i mean that's one of the reasons
why the 49ers have invited this
comparison between trey lance
mac jones justin fields because they did
publicly
even though they claimed they didn't
agonize over who they were going to take
you you put more attention on those
other guys it's just not an issue no
number one versus number two when they
get together this year jets jaguars
that's otherwise a game you'd look at
and say what else is on the reason to
watch it is you see the top two picks in
the draft we saw it with marcus mariota
and james winston week one in 2015 they
were both starting right so even if this
is week one we'll see them and it'll be
interesting and uh that that's just
check the first box that's that game and
see whether or not they'll be meeting
again in games that count the most in
january that's what both of these teams
are hoping wilson and lawrence getting
together on a regular basis in january
yeah there was no debate here you're
right it was no manning and lee from
mariota winston or whatcha golf or wentz
like none of that here you're right we
knew trevor lawrence was going to
jacksonville the day urban meyer took
the job i mean that that was like bam
it's over so when they meet this year it
is it's gonna be more about like just uh
who's got the the the the brighter
shinier new toy it's not gonna be about
like oh we picked the right one you
picked the wrong one none of that now if
the jets fans and zach wilson have a
good game and he starts to you know show
off and do stuff like that you know yeah
the jacksonville jaguar fans are gonna
hear about it and it's gonna get rubbed
in their face a little bit and then
you're gonna start to hear the like oh
was jacksonville wrong to take trevor
lawrence number one i mean yeah that
conversation is gonna get started if
that's the way the year starts out in
general that's the only way they're
going to be tied for tied to each other
but you're right there's no like oh
well you should pick this guy or we
should have picked that guy that that
didn't happen which is kind of rare when
it's what's this kind of scenario
meanwhile you mentioned gardner minshew
and yeah it's been very quiet about what
they're going to do with right i i will
say this without mentioning he who shall
not be named they're going to need to
clear him off the roster so 15 is
available for someone who may be signed
sooner rather than later
oh the great prayer king is coming to
jacksonville
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports